collante et ce en gros c'est un c'est
une mission que j'ai créé et on essaye
de rassembler les jeunes de quartiers
entre eux on part dans d'autres cités
pour faire des épreuves sportives et on
s'amusait entrée de la cohésion entre
jeunes de quartiers et les jeunes
d'ailleurs tout simplement ça donc c'est
pour les jeunes de quartier c'est un peu
un koh lanta déguisés ou tu fais des
épreuves voilà dans les quartiers et
c'est vrai que en télé voilà je te dis
moi ça m'intéressait de le faire
d'ailleurs en train de travailler
ensemble sur une formule comme ça parce
que je trouvais que c'est le franchement
l'initiative a été incroyable non donc
tu t'es dit à un moment je vais en faire
un dans une prison c'est ça exactement
pour voilà pour les détenus pour essayer
de voile à deux de leurs frères d un
truc un peu spécial alors s'il s'agit
bien les divertir un peu pour la
réinsertion parce que c'est important
aussi donc vraiment la démarche elle est
magnifique c'est ce à quoi nous
aujourd'hui on sait qu'il ya énormément
d'activité en prison bien sûr que les
gens ne savent pas et nous on a proposé
tout simplement que d'aller en prison
pour faire notre activité et ramener
notre concept dans la prison et ils ont
accepté tout simplement pas choisi la
prison de fresnes pourquoi j'habite à
fresnes a exactement voilà bien sûr
logique ou simplement non mais c'est
important de le dire voilà donc puis bon
c'est une prison meetic a quand même
freine donc forcément voit l'attitude a
choisi donc alors tu t'es dit tu a
contacté kg des parts a contacté la
prison bah j'ai contacté une personne
qui travaillait dans la prison un qui
est
professeur dans la prison qui j'ai
contacté directement et elle m'a dit que
le concept était incroyable et que
c'était possible de le faire bien sûr et
ça se fait directement alors on en parle
dans un instant parce que là tu l'as
fait et après tu as vécu un véritable
cauchemar vous avez vu un ça fait une
grosse grosse polémique et où on va dire
pourquoi toi tu n'as rien à voir là
dedans parce que je voulais absolument
que tu ailles d'exprimer ce soir tunis
toi tu parti ça partait d'un bon
sentiment tu voulais avoir des détenus
avec des peines voilà pour des courses
courtes et voilà des très graves voilà
une des petites condamnations voilà et
ça s'est transformé en cauchemar pour
toi qu'on va appeler des affaires gilles
pourquoi ça fait énormément pauline pour
deux raisons parce qu'il ya des images
de détenus dans des kartings qui ont été
jugées scandaleuses et parce que ont
participé à ces épreuves deux détenus
condamnés à l'impôt vie l'autre pour
meurtre et donc ça a choqué il faut
rappeler que djibril avait reçu
l'engagement que seuls des détenus ayant
de courtes peines et n'ayant pas été
violent envers mes victimes c'est à
participer vous n'avez pas pu avoir de
trace écrite de ça parce que sinon c'est
de la discrimination mais il avait des
garanties ils ont tous bien fait et
après on les lâche en rase campagne je
trouve ça scandaleux moi je suis
totalement de votre côté alors c'est
vrai qui brille c'est un peu ce qui lie
c'est un peu le résumé c'est ça c'est
exactement ça a beau nier aujourd'hui on
a fait une demande qui éclaire déjà
juste avant de me parler ça j'aimerais
juste dire quelque chose parce que c'est
bien de faire des communiqués mais c'est
mieux de te le dire de vive voix moi je
tenais à m'excuser auprès des victimes
et des familles des victimes bravo parce
qu'aujourd'hui nous on n'a pas choisi
ses détenus là mais je peux comprendre
qu'ils soient frustrés même si l'on a
pris la parole je peux comprendre qu'il
soit frustré et je tenais déjà m'excuser
auprès des familles des victimes avant
bravo jibril un
[Applaudissements]
serveur tombe vers lui alors que lui il
partait les services étaient atteintes
un truc incroyable et c'est vrai que ça
m'a litige et rit on va pas se mentir ça
partait d'un très bon sentiment malgré
eux il ya plein de détenus qui ont des
petites peines tu as envie voilà aussi
de sa vie des choses voilà et comme il
l'a dit il voulait pas de personnes qui
ont été violentes envers d'autres
personnes et ça c'est ce que tu avais
vraiment signaler tout de suite c'est
vraiment ce que tu voulais pas voilà
peut-être qualité même toit il tonné
après de la polémique un exactement et
c'est pour ça que j'ai supprimé la vidéo
directement moi c'est ce que je leur ai
demandé directement je leur ai dit que
moi je voulais ma seule condition c'est
qu'il n'y ait pas de détenus qui ont
fait des actes sur notre personne parce
que je sais que mes vidéos elle tourne
énormément insurgés malheureusement ça
n'a pas été respecté et voilà pourquoi
j'ai supprimé la vidéo directement quand
je les suis
vachement gibril c'est un jeune qui
bouge qui avec alim projet de salle a su
agen où sa fantastique en revanche le
projet en lui-même chose il était
complètement insensé et c'est à
l'administration pénitentiaire que jean
me principalement parce que avoir des
projets pour éviter que les gens
retournent en prison donc les carnets
des oeuvres de ré affaires sont très
bien là le principal but de la pression
c'est ne pas y aller et comment on peut
faire peur à des jeunes comment un
inspecteur police nous dira je n'arrête
décor
au
contraire c'est grâce à des lycées du
rib météo
ont dit n'importe quoi
une seule est ce que tu es de l'émotion
les gens voyaient je pense comme un
vieux con j'en vois pas quels sont les
autres par exemple prisonniers qui font
du quartier zy'va ça y est c'est la fête
en prison c'est pas parce qu'ils ont
fait une activité une fois sur une
échelle jamais qu'on jouera le reste on
doit publiquement son choix l'itc
imagine parce que j'ai pas été en prison
mais j'imagine dans des cellules qui
sont petits qui sont parfois insalubres
c'est normal qu'il fasse des activités
ils n'ont pas compte du côlon test pour
faire des activités en prison et que
l'on tait sa face à favorise la
réinsertion et le lien cela surtout pour
la réinsertion s'est ensuite arrêté de
céder à l'émotion des réseaux sociaux
vous voyez une image de prisonniers font
du karting vous en déduisez mai c'est la
fête en prison je pense que c'est pas la
fête en prison bah oui c'est justement
parce que c'est pas la fête en prison
fallait pas beaucoup les gens
j'aimerais j'aimerais qu'on jibril
aujourd'hui toi tu viens d'en faire
pourquoi parce que ben malheureusement
et plein de personnes qui n'ont pas
compris le message qu'on avait voulu
véhiculer comme j'en ai un je prendrai
comme jean-michel moi qui nomme et
jean-michel exactement nous aujourd'hui
en fait je comprends que les gens soient
énervés et indignée tout simplement
parce que nous on a essayé de mettre
certaines variations mais on comprend
l'indignation on nous a empêchés de
mettre ces images là on voulait montrer
les jeunes de chez moi l'ont vu en elles
sont rentrées dans la prison ils ont vu
que la prison ce n'est pas le club med
comme disent certains ça fait peur nous
certaines personnes qui nous ont
empêchés de mettre ces images là les
images qui font peur et qui montrent
réellement la prison et je comprends
aujourd'hui que les gens sont indignés
aussi comme jean-michel parce que quand
on leur dit que c'est avec leur argent
c'est ça on a qu'on a payé en fait en
fait le message était mauvais serre que
les gens qui pensent comme jean-michel
ont vu que des images qui véhicule un
très mauvais message alors que à la base
l'initiative c'était vraiment pour la
réinsertion et et c'est ce que tu fais
au quotidien exactement alors
aujourd'hui en plus il ya un autre truc
c'est que collante est ce tu n'as pas le
droit d'utiliser le nom colons thèse
puisque koh lanta la société c'est la
même société que que fort boyard tu as
dit que tu devais pas parce que ça ça
nique c'est l'image de koh lanta dans le
coup c'est à dire en c et l'iran senad
au sénat non mais c'est naze c'est nous
et qui soit tu fais un truc qui était un
coin mais comme ils ont vu ça à cause de
la peau que derrière ils sont dit mais
on veut pas être associé à kohl en thèse
ça aussi c'est encore des gens qui n'y
connaissent rien ou dit non mais jolie
qui n'y connaissent rien qui ont vu
juste à il ya une polémique sur collante
est abattu les études tu fais un
courrier tu leur dis qu'on veut plus que
ça s'appelle collante s il savait même
pas qu'elle est la polémique connaissent
rien il s'intéresse à rien il ça va rien
céder nul non mais c'est vrai et c'est
insupportable ils se sont dit qu'est ce
qu'on va faire on va attaquer le pôle
jibril qui caniche est yves incroyable
et on va lui dire tu enlèves colons
taisent parce que ça va salir koh lanta
croyez vraiment quand les gens vont
regarder koh lanta est elle et il faut
qu'il ait les mêmes problèmes de ces
gens qui ont fait ça c'est qu'ils
pensent que les téléspectateurs sont des
débiles non mais oh que nous on est
débile les gens savent très bien faire
la différence entre koh lanta et
collante s voilà donc les îles bon ça
non mais on croit que c'est collante est
le truc dans les prisons non mais faut
vraiment je pense qu'il est si c'est ce
programme est d'aider non mais il faut
vraiment être dans un autre monde en
fait ils sont pas dans le monde actuel
ils vivent ils sont à côté de la plaque
ils vivent dans leur petit univers de
télévision des années 90 et ils savent
pas ce qui se passe ils savent pas ce
qui se passe dans la société et voilà
ils s'envoient des procès et ça envoie
des lettres et sa fédé ça fait les
choses pour interdire tel truc ou tel
truc laisser faire la société souple et
ça se passe très bien laisser faire des
gens comme djibril qui fonction des
initiatives incroyable et moi djibril
moi je te dis je te tire mon chapeau
parce que ce que tu fais c'est
exceptionnel sur s'ils ne veulent pas
qu'ils s'appellent collante est un
jardin castaldi a une très bonne idée tu
peux l'appeler touche pas touche pas à
ce que tu veux voilà je la regardais
c'est vrai non mais tu vois là je te le
dis je te vois je te passe le nom et
nous on te fera jamais voilà je te n'y
aura jamais de procès mais c'est
insupportable ces gens qui vivent dans
leur monde qui ne comprennent rien et
c'est pour ça que leurs émissions de
plantes voilà parce que koh lanta
s'abaisse fort boyard ça a bien marché
cet été c'est vrai et ab qu'arrive la
rentrée ça baisse aussi parce que vrai
c'est une émission d'été ils sont à côté
de la plaque excusez moi oui moi sauf
qu'on peut se dire il est ce qu'il a
fait est tout à fait remarquable bien
sûr je devrais il devrait même
s'associer avec le ministère de la
justice s'est développé ça dans d'autres
prisons tout schuss mais je pense que
tenue de prix de peines courtes en
conservant pas toujours en parler
d'ailleurs je vis et je vais essayer
d'en parler au ministre de la justice
moretti café les chocs étaient au
courant là je suis prêt mais je pense
que j'aurais eu eric dupond moretti je
pense que je vais essayer de m'en parler
je te lis et faire une rencontre entre
vous s'il veut bien que vous rencontriez
et que avon est d'abord y est ça un
loyer pour que peut-être au lieu qu'on
parle d'un truc qui a fait une polémique
justement pour avancer au confort essaie
de faire un truc plus construit ou avec
on essaie vraiment de leur faire de
refaire d'autres choses avec pousse le
jeune même voilà des jeunes auraient que
tu refasses encore en plus gros oui si
tu veux que je t'ai de là dessus des
matchs est là et je vais essayer
d'organiser une rencontre je vais je
vais essayer de le contacter on lui
proposait qu'il rend compte et que
peut-être tu te met en contact avec le
ministre de la justice pour avancer là
dessus et on court terme en sortir
grandi de cette affaire
merci mon dieu et on va tout faire pour
que l'on peut dire encore collante est
pour l'instant nous ne codent ça existe
sur les antennes du groupe canal plus et
on jeudi et on va voir avec le ministère
de la justice s'ils veulent s'associer à
nous pour faire encore plus grandir ce
projet d'accord du mois n'y a pas de
problème merci d'y mourir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]